hey i'm diego tinoco i'm brett gray
what's up i'm sierra capri hi i'm jason
janelle i'm jessica marie garcia what's
up guys i'm julia macias and we are
doing the wired autocomplete interview
yes
we're touring 2022. i'm the manager hit
me up on the block tour on the block
what
is ethnicity what color is that the
question or is he
middle name javier i know close it's
really pretty alejandro alejandro
oh yeah there's a lady gaga song yeah
and you're cuban uh no cuban you're
mexican and colombian um mexican my
mother's colombian and her father was
colombian so i'm like a mix beautiful
what character did diego tinaco play in
teen wolf yeah
[Music]
yeah that was the first um that was my
first gig i think i was like 17 at the
time
and uh yeah i booked i booked mtv's teen
wolf and it was crazy because i grew up
watching that show does diego tinoco
have tattoos
no i don't actually he's clean zero i
don't i have zero tattoos at the moment
let's document this in time because i
might get a bunch after this show guys
we're getting on my black tattoo oh yeah
i have a design can i grab my phone on
your body i would take a call i got a
general idea no because i'm not getting
a nomi so it's a little know me but with
a skull face and then we thought about
maybe putting it inside of a dollar bill
yeah like as a the case in the bill but
we're going to get that it gets bigger
and bigger it's about to say i'm ready
no no i made it up but i didn't want it
did diego tinoco
shave his head for the last three
dedication we've been uh we've been
shaving my head i tried to use a bald
cap for some of the stuff but um
but no no they weren't they weren't for
it so we shaved it cool and on camera
now it's growing it's growing back
finally you know they got one take at
that i know diego tinoco
car currently i do not have a car i just
got rid of my bmw and uh and yeah i
ordered a electric porsche so it's on
the way four months
yeah i'm sorry
you know you have electric electric
constructions
that means like personality i can
understand that because you would not
get that at all from the show
i thought it was like how is she and
you're like google how is here
i think it's someone who watched me on
the show and they're like how is sierra
capri
i like to think i'm nice but
sarah's very sarah's one of the most
giving people you will ever meet in the
whole year
how old was sierra capri when filming on
my block oh i swear to god if i get this
question we were babies i want to say i
don't even remember i just know it was
true young definitely wasn't 21 no i
don't think i think she was like 20 or
something not even i don't even know
that's we celebrated all of your 20
years yeah i was like we all celebrated
birthdays together yeah
who is sierra capri
sister it's me
i have a couple this is definitely one
of my sisters blood related don't go
gross i have three brothers three older
brothers no sisters but no real jessica
she's my sister sierra capri
hidden figures yes
and she's oh my god
that was probably one of the best set
experiences yeah i was in hidden figures
i was an extra met taraji p henson shout
out mr raji she was so sweet
she was like how did you get on the set
you look 12.
yeah it was a really fun experience and
that's where i actually met the person
who helped me film my audition for on my
blog we love sierra we love sierra
who is jessica marie garcia related to
my mother
what does that mean i feel like they're
like she had to know someone to get in
this business she's gotta be married
is my great uncle
does jessica marie garcia
speak spanish
she's getting better and better every
day when she talks
like day 430.
i still haven't gone past airport street
signs
jessica marie garcia favorite color red
blood red
she wears it well wow i love it
google my wedding photos oh my god the
lips yeah
jessica marie garcia and oh no
dove cameron that's my girl that she
will be my maddie for life yeah i mean
i've known her since she was like
16 17 years old and i was um not so um i
was kind of her big sister on that show
and still am like she is she's a star
i'm so proud of her she is a star yeah
i love this
who is jason janae who is jason janie
what do you think it is it's dating
does it rhyme with mariah carey it does
are there any that you want to say or
shoot your shot i'm not stealing no tea
i'm not spilling no tea because we might
run into these people yeah i know she's
always in the uh okay
don't do that never show your cords
i'm sorry i'm sorry what episode of
blank was jason law order law order an
episode of law
i don't remember like on set it was
referenced as the hamilton episode
because i did it with anthony ramos and
david diggs it was an amazing time and
like
anthony for doing amazing amazing things
thank you i learned something new every
day all right where are jason janeio
blank from that's okay i think it's our
parents
on it's gonna pop off um
my mom
was born in new york and my dad was born
in the dominican republic but my mom is
also dominican so you know we just all
from the east coast 100 dominicans yeah
100 dominican okay is jason janeio
related to blank
what do you guys think oh rami malik
maybe
my board is just
a trick board am i related to romney
that's the wrong answer oh yes yes
i'm sorry remember remember the time
your mom had me
that was a compliment anyways romney i'm
missing a 20-something christmas gifts
presents and an oscar award yeah and
half the oscar
okay okay what
school did brett grey go to did we know
this uh
arts high school the philadelphia high
school for the creative and performing
arts
and i did not go to college
because none of us did what is that how
did brett grey
um just a little show on this one
streaming service called
on the blockchain
here i got you i got you we doing this
together okay boom does brett gray
that means they're looking for oh
they're looking for gifts of you
or is it gypsy yeah netflix where are my
y'all where are my gifts at everybody
got them but me it was peanut butter no
jiffy is peanut butter it's gift jif you
know whatever
who does uh julio macias play in selena
he's a great performer too i checked him
out after you played yeah he's
phenomenal he's an incredible singer he
wrote some of the classics that you all
know
um and i didn't come on i didn't meet
him until after the show now he hits me
up and it's fun
that's awesome come on heck yeah it is
you guys think what are you guys married
yeah single
sing
sorry
ring and tattoo on it wow
that's how you know
what episodes of blank is julio macias
episodes
[Applause]
also i've only worked with female
directors on shows that's something
really cool
so i worked with gina on that it was
like two lions remember yeah it was fun
they had they had ran a great set i had
a blast and i had no idea i didn't know
anything either fun facts can julio
macias blank what are you guys saying
really really really sing and yes he can
yes not just singer songwriter too right
and plays a guitar yeah he's a great
musician on my block what is on my block
let's see about
character is your soulmate
oscars is clearly caesar
[Laughter]
facts where is
little ricky on my block that's a really
good question
that's the question we've all been
wondering stay tuned oh my god is ricky
really nice
a dream
okay
okay can i debunk this one i also
started this so i watch y'all i started
it too oh okay okay so we were doing a
tour of the sets yes and we were going
from room to room and the person that
was directing it was like oh it's so
interesting there's a dream catcher in
almost every room and i was like oh and
he's like maybe you should say something
like oh maybe it's all a dream none of
it is real everything is real
we just like dream catchers i definitely
trolled on twitter and uh one day i
tweeted hey on my block fans remember um
the biggie line it was all a dream i
felt that so um
yeah it was kind of a stir it's fun it's
fun this is a double whammy is
caesar from on my block single
dead
is on my block
worth watching yeah that's a question
ask our three seasons at netflix
you ask a friend that or like ask
twitter you know google is on my blog
i have questions i have a question you
asked yahoo answers
jeeves yes did you ask me thank you yeah
thank you thank you
thank you so much thanks for having us i
had no idea this fool was on jane the
verse i had no idea
and i had no idea jessica thought it was
jiff i did it's peanut butter also it's
really cool that people are looking us
up yeah